wer war er
manche nennen ihn den vater indiens
unter unabhängigkeit anderer auch
mahatma die große säle verehrt als
apostel der gewaltlosigkeit bereits zu
lebzeiten legende
[Musik]
er wurde zum sinnbild für das schicksal
des ganzen indischen volkes
und mehr noch für die hoffnung aller
unterdrückten dieser welt
mein leben ist meine botschaft sagte er
und schon von anfang an seinem mythos
mit
[Musik]
monkey ball step faces tag alaba in
südafrika
drei südafrika bahnhof pietermaritzburg
woanders kann stand gandhi ein
24-jähriger indischer anwalt wird aus
einem verweis reservierten anteil der
ersten klasse gelaufen
damit legte gott das fundament für mein
leben in südafrika und säte den samen
für den kampf um selbstachtung wird kann
die jahre später in seinen memoiren
schreiben und das ereignis in einem
gründungsmythos verwandeln die jahre in
südafrika sind entscheiden ausgang die
wurde dann ja er war nichts als er ankam
ein kleiner provinz advocard nicht
besonders brillant seine wandlung
vollzog sich spektakulär aber nach unten
an
geboren wird kann die in indien
seine familie gehört einer höheren kaste
an
er studiert in london bevor er anwalt in
südafrika wird indien und südafrika
gehören damals beide zum britischen
commonwealth
sie sind kolonien im weltumspannenden
reich des british empire
von dem es heißt dass die sonne dort
niemals untergeht 300.000 in der leben
in südafrika einige hatten ihr glück
erfolgreich versucht und sie in reiche
kaufleute die gandhi nun vertritt
die meisten von ihnen aber arbeiten als
kulis ausgebeutete hilfsarbeiter in den
docks in den minen und auf den feldern
allesamt sind sie benachteiligt von
wahlen ausgeschlossen dürfen sie sich
nicht frei bewegen kolonialisiert dieser
unterlegene status ist es der den jungen
anwalt kann die zutiefst abstößt und
obwohl er später von einer göttlichen
offenbarung gegen rassismus spricht
schließt er die schwarzen in südafrika
nicht in seine nun beginnenden kampf ein
vorurteile sind auch bei indern tief
verwurzelt sie lehnen eine
gleichstellung mit schwarzem ab 1894
gründet gandhi mit namhaften indischen
intellektuellen in natal indien kongress
dessen ziel es ist innerhalb des
britischen empire
gleiche rechte zu erhalten und in der
kolonialen hierarchie aufzusteigen nicht
aber sie zu überwinden
[Musik]
nach und nach trat er als der wahre
führer der indischen gemeinschaft in
südafrika hervor
wie aber gelingt ihm das gandhi ist jung
und gilt als schüchtern
er verfügt jedoch über ein wichtiges
werkzeug 1903 gründet er eine
wochenzeitschrift die er selbst
finanziert schreibt und publiziert die
indien ob indien
sie erscheint in englisch hindi tamil
und bugatti in den muttersprachen all
der unterdrückten und benachteiligten
für deren rechte und würde er eintreten
will
gandhi war sich bewusst darüber dass die
indischen gruppen in südafrika zerstreut
waren und er musste sie zusammenbringen
er musste ihnen auch eine stimme geben
und so war die zeitung eine ideale
plattform für beides seine ideen zu
verbreiten und gemeinschaft zu stiften
[Musik]
dem späten neunzehnten jahrhundert
begann dann die eine aktive politische
rolle in südafrika zu spüren
es war zugleich eine zeit der medialen
revolution
es gibt telegrafen telefone und
massenmedien in form von zeitungen diese
kommunikationsrevolution passte
wunderbar in seine strategie indien ob
indien spiegelte einen teil meines
lebens woche für woche floss meiner
seele in die kolumnen schreibt ganz über
die zeitung knüpft er ein enges band mit
seinen lesern als die zeit kommt würde
das zu nutzen wissen
1906 ist es soweit die briten verkünden
ein neues melderegister in das sich alle
inder eintragen sollen eine weitere
demütigung
gandhi wird der kopf des protestes er
bringt die inder dazu sich dem gesetz zu
verweigern mit dem risiko von
gefangenschaft und tod aber ohne jemals
gewalt anzuwenden
gandhi geht für seine überzeugung ins
gefängnis auch viele seiner mitstreiter
verbüßen haftstrafen unser ganzer kampf
basiert darauf sagt kann die uns selbst
den herausforderungen auszusetzen und
sie niemand anderem aufzuerlegen
ob ihn da oder europäer das fundament
für den gewaltfreien widerstand gegen
fremdherrschaft ist bewegt und gandhi
wird ihn für immer verkörpern wie kam er
zu dieser philosophie
er bezieht sich auf den amerikaner henry
david thoreau und dessen idee des
zivilen ungehorsams den russen lew
tolstoi mit dem er korrespondiert und
die bawag kita den gesang gottes den
großen text des hinduismus diesem
entnimmt gandhi eine wesentliche
grundhaltung für seine lehre schade
niemals einem lebendigen wesen ob mensch
oder tier
[Musik]
elektra moderner ultramodern mehr noch
um most modern vielleicht indem er die
wichtigsten ideen des westens derzeit
mit uralten hindu traditionen in seiner
person verband um daraus eine neue
philosophie zu schmieden
eine neue art zu leben und zu handeln
[Musik]
den begriff passiver widerstand lebt
kann die ab er kreiert einen neuen
begriff für seine bewegung sagt die
agrar- wirken durch die kraft der
wahrheit widerstand leistende sagt
agrarius setzten sich der gewalt aus
antworten aber niemals mit gewalt damit
beeindrucken sie durch moralische
überlegenheit in bezug auf ihre
unterdrücker
daran ist nichts passiert im gegenteil
es war sehr aktiv weil es
unbeschreibliche stärke von jenen
erforderte gs in die tat umsetzen
laut kann die beeinflussen ihn in den
anfangsjahren in südafrika vor allem die
ideen des englischen ökonomen john
ruskin ruskin entwirft eine gegenwelt
zum modernen kapitalismus ein lebendiges
miteinander
basierend auf kooperation teilen und
sozialer gerechtigkeit
ich entschloss mich mein ganzes leben zu
ändern um die ideale dieser schriften zu
verwirklichen wird kann die später sagen
er gründet zwei ashrams kloster ähnliche
siedlungen auf dem land in südafrika
zuerst die phoenix und später die
tollsten farben auf der er wohnt umgeben
von seinen anhängern
jeder dort hat dieselben arbeiten im
haus und auf dem feld zu erledigen
der lohn ist für alle gleich das leben
genügsam gandhi setzt strikte disziplin
durch und ist der erste der sich bis zum
äußersten daran hält er liegt das
keuschheitsgelübde der hindus ab und
sagt damit allen körperlichen
beziehungen zu seiner frau der mutter
seiner fünf kinder casper sein körper
wird ein mittel des widerstandes
gandhi verstand seine körper praxis und
insbesondere seine art der askese und
enthaltsamkeit in bezug auf sex und
ernährung als einen weg seine
spirituellen kräfte und seine
wirksamkeit zu bündeln
sein körper konnte so zu einem super
medium werden dass hoch aufgeladen in
die öffentlichkeit
beispiel diente und als vorbild in
seiner wirkung ansteckt die indischen
massen konnten auf die symbole dann geht
es wie auf einen saado einen heiligen
der alle materiellen besitztümer
aufgegeben hat reagieren
zur gleichen zeit sahen sie den krieger
krishna und anstatt physisch zu den
waffen zu greifen sprach gandhi von
moralischen und spirituellen kämpfen
ihm war klar dass er für die mehrheit
der inder die hindus waren seine aktion
nicht erklären musste sie würden seine
botschaft intuitiv verstehen
[Musik]
willkommen martin ein team platin am 6
november 1913 ruft gandhi seine anhänger
zu einem friedlichen marsch durch
transvaal einer region die für asiaten
und schwarze verboten ist auf 2000
männer frauen und kinder kommen seinem
ruf nach und protestieren gegen gesetze
die ihre rechte einschränken
die repression ist brutal gandhi wird
erneut ins gefängnis gesperrt
aber er hat gewonnen angesichts des
ausmaßes der bewegung erklären sich die
briten zu gesprächen mit den indern
bereit
es ist sein erster sieg aus trauer um
die während der kampagne getöteten
saties trägt kann die eine einfache
weiße tunika
der anwalt im dreiteiligen anzug ist
seitdem für immer verschwunden sein ruhm
überwindet die grenzen von südafrika bis
indien wird kann die nun mahatma genannt
die große heilige seele
[Musik]
1915 ist gandhi bereit in sein
heimatland mit seinen 300 millionen
einwohnern zurückzukehren und sich dort
seiner lebensaufgabe zu stellen
im kampf gegen die britische
vorherrschaft für die selbstbestimmung
des indischen volkes an die tritt der
indischen kongresspartei bei und wird
einige jahre später deren führer
er lässt die elite partei südafrikas
hinter sich und vertritt nun
hunderttausende von mitgliedern von den
hohen über die mittleren kasten bis zu
den armen bauern bringt kann die nun die
menschen zusammen
[Musik]
1921 initiiert er einen boykott gegen
britische waren eine weitere sagrada
gegen die brutalität der
kolonialherrschaft
die indien um seine wenigen rohstoffe
wie baumwolle bringt baumwolle wird zu
der zeit aus indien heraus in fabriken
nach großbritannien transportiert dort
zu kleidung verarbeitet und wieder an
die inder zurückverkauft ein ungerechtes
system das indische souveränität außer
kraft setzt
[Musik]
um diese zurückzugewinnen führt kann dir
ein werkzeug an das kk ein spinnrad alle
inder sind angehalten täglich eigenes
gern zu spinnen und am eigenen gewarnt
den kadi zu arbeiten
[Musik]
das spinnrad wird ein kraftvolles symbol
der emanzipation sowohl von der
britischen herrschaft als auch von den
industriellen konsum gesellschaften des
westens ein ganz auf die indische
gesellschaft zugeschnittenes projekt das
auf genügsamkeit und der rückkehr zur
traditionellen ländlichen
selbstversorgung basiert und auch wenn
nur wenige seiner anhänger ist
tatsächlich in die praxis umsetzen das
spinnrad wird zum standard und zum
symbol der zukünftigen flagge des
eigenständigen indien
ob es nun das spinnen ist das bin rand
oder das tragen bestimmter kleidung
alle diese sachen sind leicht zu
verstehen sie benötigen keine weit
schweifenden erklärungen sind sehr
effektive momente kleine inszenierungen
die sehr gut funktionieren weil sie eine
komplizierte politische realität auf
einfache und szenische weise vermitteln
darin ist gern die den machern
kommerzieller werbung ähnlich und
unterscheidet sich zugleich von sie
arbeiten ebenfalls mit der reduzierung
auf sehr einfache akustische und
optische zeichen aber gandhi forderte
damit zugleich zu einer art ethischer
selbst der forschung heran
das ist eines der dinge die dann die
wirklich neu erfunden hat
am 22
september 1921 wogt ein aufruhr durch
die stadt mathura der mahatma soll
bekannt gegeben haben dass er vom
heutigen tage an nur noch ein einfaches
weißes leinentuch tragen wird in
dortmund einen schal um seine schultern
[Musik]
gandhi war ein überragender schöpfer von
bildern um den schmerz des einfachen
mannes den er vertreten möchte zu
verstehen sagt gandhi muss er dessen
leben leben und der einfache mann hat
nichts
er ist arm er ist nackt das ablegen
seines gewandes ist also teil seiner
strategie mit ihm zu sympathisieren sich
hinter ihn zu stellen kann die ist kein
geborener redner
er hat keine tragende stimme und er weiß
das und doch wo immer er erscheint
versammelt er menschenmengen
es ist als ob nur seine anwesenheit
ausreicht seine botschaft zu verbreiten
er erscheint als eine verkörperung des
egoistischen daran seine anwesenheit ist
die anwesenheit des göttlichen
die indische gesellschaft ist sehr
heterogen und weit sensibler gegenüber
bildern als gegen überschrift eine
gesellschaft in der die rate der
alphabeten damals gering war
so richtete man sich mit bildern an die
massen nicht mit texten
mit landon tuch schal und wanderstab ist
seine schmale silhouette für alle wieder
erkennbar
gandhis körper wird zu einer ikone einem
symbol für den kampf eines ganzen volkes
der zukünftige premierminister
großbritanniens winston churchill
wettert gegen den halbnackten fakir der
sich dem empire widersetzen
aber in wahrheit sind die briten
entmutigt nichts kann ganz stoppen
in der service pack wissen meist in der
heimschule sault ste hen
[Musik]
am 12 märz 1930 brechen gandhi und etwa
70 seiner jünger von ihrem sabarimala
schrein zu fuß zum meer auf
386 kilometer weiter werden sie auf
hunderte männer frauen und kinder
treffen am strand von dundee in der
dämmerung fühlt kann die eine kleine
menge mehr wasser und etwas salz ab eine
unbedeutende geste nein eine
symbolträchtige auflehnung gegen die
kolonialmacht nur briten haben das recht
in indien salz zu gewinnen
ein unverzichtbares gut dass sie zudem
mit hohen steuern belegt haben
salz ein symbol kolonialer
ungerechtigkeit
[Musik]
mit einem einzigen akt hat gandhi das
wichtigste auf den punkt gebracht es ist
nicht länger eine frage der verhandlung
um eine gerechte es geht nun um die
totale unabhängigkeit indiens durch die
symbolik des salzes gelingt kann die der
internationale durchbruch mit hilfe der
ausländischen presse erlangen er und
seine bewegung weltruhm journalisten es
gab diese intuitive sympathien dieser
art fand in realistischen antikolonialen
bewegung
er sagt ihm dass sie sich als teil der
bewegung fühlen müssten nicht nur als
beobachter und reporte und ob sie
wollten oder nicht kann die schaffte es
dass sie dabei waren
das ist dass sie nie dieses mannes nach
dem salz marsch wird gandhi verhaftet
seine frau castor bar und eine seiner
berühmten mitstreiterinnen die dichterin
sappho genie naidoo machen weiter im mai
1930 führen sie einen neuen protest
gegen das britische salz monopol an den
salz minen von da das sana erneuert
naidoo für die stadt ja gratis das
manifest
ihr werdet geschlagen werden aber ihr
werdet euch nicht wehren
united press 21 mai 1930
die polizei griff mit stöcken an die
freiwilligen leisteten keinen widerstand
ich hörte das entsetzliche geräusch von
schlägen auf ungeschützte schädel
[Musik]
der amerikanische journalist web miller
der das schrieb ist der einzige
westliche augenzeuge sein schockierender
bericht ändert die öffentliche meinung
weltweit die brutale methoden der briten
werden nun angeprangert als moralischer
bankrott des empire
die salz marschierer leisten keinen
widerstand als die polizei sie schlägt
gandhi hat gewaltlos die gewalt besiegt
[Musik]
auch der westen lässt ihm öffentliche
weilen zu kommen
im januar 1931 kürt ihn das time
-magazin zum mann des jahres
sie sind meist heftig 6 mrd
[Musik]
die briten haben eine zweite runde tisch
konferenz einberufen um die indische
krise zu lösen
gandhi ist der einzige vertreter der
indischen kongresspartei
er verlangt die absolute unabhängigkeit
seines heimatlandes
dennoch wird er wie ein star empfangen
kleidung und gefolge erregen aufsehen
insbesondere seine treue anhängerin
madeleine slate war eine kuriose
erscheinung
mehr noch als der halbnackte fakir
selbst an der seite der tochter eines
britischen vize admirals mit einem
weißen sari und geschorenem kopf
das war unglaublich für gandhi war sie
sehr unterstützend sie verlieh seiner
mission und seiner botschaft zusätzliche
politische und moralische autorität
sie verkörperte eine art lebendig
beliebtes großbritannien
unglaublich dieses besuch in london ist
die hohe schule der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit
er weigert sich in den teuren vierteln
londons zu wohnen und wählt einen
stadtteil der arbeiterklasse im east end
[Musik]
und obwohl die konservative britische
presse ihn wegen dieses aufrührerischen
verhaltens zur destabilisierung des
empire kritisiert schließen ihn einige
london eye in ihr herz charlie chaplin
persönlich möchte ihn unbedingt treffen
und als er nach nordengland geht zu den
textilfabriken die vom indischen boykott
britischer waren den gandhi verantwortet
hatte schwer getroffen sind heißen in
die arbeiter wie einen helden willkommen
[Musik]
gandhi tritt erfolgreich als vertreter
aller unterdrückten seien sie in der
oder briten auf und er gewinnt den kampf
um die öffentliche meinung auf dem
heimischen boden seines gegners
[Musik]
dj
der von den briten einberufene runde
tisch allerdings bedeutet ein scheitern
für gandhi die frage der indischen
unabhängigkeit gelangt gar nicht auf die
tagesordnung
zudem ist er in seinem eigenen lager mit
widerspruch konfrontiert sein opponent
ist wie madame sie am bett kann
er repräsentiert die unterprivilegierte
kaste indiens die unberührbaren
auch kann den verstand sich immer als
vertreter der unberührbaren der hd jones
kinder gottes wie er sie nannte er
empfängt sie in seinem ashram und setzt
sich unermüdlich dafür ein dass auch sie
tempel und öffentliche brunnen benutzen
dürfen
und dennoch hält er am indischen
kastensystem fest indem er das fundament
der indischen gesellschaft sieht am bett
karl dagegen verlangt die absolute
abschaffung dieses kastensystems als
überholt und ungerecht dieser bruch
zwischen den beiden männern wird auch
die gesellschaft spalten den wie nie und
so leben die ärmsten der inder die
mehrheitlich der untersten kaste
angehörten
traurigerweise gandhi kategorisch ab und
rutsche kategorie conti ihr vater der
nation ihr spiritueller anführer wird
führer des kampfes für soziale
gerechtigkeit java am bett kam und nicht
ganz und das ist bis heute so kann die
erreicht nichts in london schiebt er
deshalb seine rückkehr nach indien
hinaus eine handvoll bewunderer
überzeugt ihn in europa zu bleiben
er startet eine improvisierte tour
ein mann hatte bereits so lange an
gandhi geglaubt dass gandhi ihn in genf
besuchen will
der mann ist umarow long pazifist und
autor träger des literaturnobelpreises
in der schweiz im ruhestand gandhi und
er haben sich nie zuvor getroffen aber
über jahre hin korrespondiert romario
hatte daran gearbeitet gandhis botschaft
in frankreich zu verbreiten
in einem essay von 1924 verglich er ihm
mit einem indischen christus eine
erlöserfigur für die welt wie viele
andere war auch in dem widerspruch
zwischen der ablehnung von gewalt und
der hoffnung auf eine revolution
gefangen so versuchte er zwischen 1920
und 1930 eine synthese zwischen der
proletarischen revolution und der von
gandhi exemplarisch gelebten
gewaltlosigkeit zu finden
er hoffte dass gandhis beispiel als
inspiration für die europäische
arbeiterklasse dienen könnte und sie zum
aufstand gegen den faschismus ermutigen
würde der in italien bereits an der
macht war und in deutschland zu
übernehmen drohte
gandhi ist nun eine universale ikonische
figur und hält seine prinzipien für
universal eine illusion
nach ihren treffen glaubt sogar oma
rolle nicht mehr daran kann die mochte
eine demokratie wie großbritannien durch
entlarven ihrer fehler erschüttern
aber die totalitären staaten im von
wirtschaftlichen und politischen kämpfen
zerrütteten europa besitzen andere
moralische voraussetzungen sie treten
für unbegrenzte rohe gewalt ein
angesichts dessen scheint gewaltfreier
widerstand machtlos
romário erwidert gandhi ich kann
gewaltlosigkeit für mich selbst wählen
aber kann ich eine ganze generation
auffordern sich im namen der
gewaltlosigkeit zu opfern
gandhi war für roller nicht länger der
quell politischer hoffnung fuße des
politik bevor dann die wieder den
dampfer nach indien besteigt macht er
einen letzten besuch in rom der papst
verweigert ihm eine audienz um nicht
umsonst angereist zu sein nimmt er eine
einladung des dusche benito mussolini an
mussolini herrscht bereits seit 1925 als
faschistischer diktator über italien
diese bilder zeugen von einem
aufeinandertreffen wie es
widersprüchlicher nicht sein kann
der anwalt der gewaltlosigkeit folgt
einem aufmarsch der schwarzhemden
[Musik]
du musst ist die frage ob dann die 1931
dem verführerischen charme seines
eigenen mythos zum opfer fiel
der charme und was sind das womit er
dachte er hätte die presse gut im griff
er wäre der meister der public relations
züge die aufmerksamkeit der presse auf
sich und würde sie dazu bringen seine
botschaft zu verbreiten
aber fakt ist wenn man den film sieht
der für mussolini gedreht wurde
das kann die gar nichts bewirkt hat bei
diesem besuch
es war ein moment der demütigung jahre
später wird kann die noch einmal ähnlich
handeln in einem brief von trauriger
berühmtheit drängt er hitler prinzipiell
auf gewalt zu verzichten
er ging in dieselbe falle wie viele
europäer zu der zeit erst in italien
später in deutschland indem sie nämlich
an die soziale ader der faschistischen
führer glaubten
natürlich muss man england kritisieren
auch frankreich aber sie waren nicht
faschistisch
es gibt da eine rote linie hat kann die
europa missverstanden
in der von überall auf steigenden gefahr
bleibt seine botschaft unerhört und sein
image verblasst
die wochenschauen zeigen eine triumphale
rückkehr nach indien
aber die realität ist komplexer gandhi
wird erneut von den briten inhaftiert
sein ansehen schwindet kritisiert und an
den rand gedrängt entschließt er sich
1934 die kongress partei zu verlassen
so war dann die tatsächlich am ende
seiner wenn sie so wollen ikonisierung
politisch viel schwächer als je zuvor
er setzt sich in seinem ashram instagram
zur ruhe
wie schon auf der tolstoi farm in
südafrika lebt er ein diszipliniertes
asketisches leben umgeben von seiner
getreuen
er wird nach wie vor konsultiert doch
spielt er ab jetzt in der politik eine
hintergrund rolle
[Musik]
der neue aufsteigende stern der
indischen kongresspartei ist der spätere
premierminister des unabhängigen indien
java halal nehru er pilgert einige male
nach c wagram um sich mit gandhi zu
beraten und dessen segen zu empfangen
selbst jetzt bleibt gandhi der angehende
vater der nation eine rechtmäßige
instanz und autorität für indien und
darüber hinaus
[Musik]
howard universität neunter september
1935 lieber mister gandhi ich bin der
vorsitzende einer delegation
amerikanischer schwarzer die bei der
bewegung der christlichen studenten
indiens zu gast sein werden
ich habe vor sie unbedingt in ihrem
aschheim zu besuchen
ich lese ihre schriften seit jahren und
es gibt so viele dinge die ich mit ihnen
diskutieren möchte freundlichen grüßen
howard samen firmen war einer der
führenden religiösen intellektuellen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ich möchte mich auf ihn als einen der
geistigen architekten der modernen
bürgerrechtsbewegung beziehen
normalerweise datieren wir deren beginn
in die späten 40er und frühen 50er jahre
mit montgomery und king
aber die leute haben lange vorher um
ihre rechte gekämpft
konfrontiert mit institutionalisierten
rassismus und rassentrennung waren
schwarze amerikaner sehr früh fasziniert
von gandhis experiment bereits in den
frühen 20er jahren tauschte mahatma
regelmäßig briefe mit den pionieren der
schwarzen bürger und
menschenrechtsbewegung aus wie hier
david gibor sagt ja grad
der gewaltfreie widerstand der
unterdrückten geht so zusammen mit den
politischen und spirituellen
bestrebungen der bürgerrechtler oftmals
in verbindung mit der protestantischen
kirche wie im falle von reverend
hauptthemen professor der theologie und
baptistenprediger
[Musik]
das treffen mit gandhi und sein eigenes
nachdenken über gewaltlosigkeit brachten
den nachweis oder eine bestätigung für
das was er bereits gefühlt und worüber
er tief nachgedacht hatte die ganze idee
der moralischen überzeugungsarbeit und
die dies in der schwarzen gemeinde seit
langem gab von christlicher
nächstenliebe sonst jeden lieben die
lieder handeln davon alle sogar eine
unterdrücker wie hilft man unterjochten
menschen der keine einen ort zu kommen
an dem ihre liebe für ihre unterdrücker
nicht ihre selbstliebe und würde
untergräbt
[Musik]
durch dieses rätsel arbeitete sich
firmen
das war teil seines anliegens dass er
mit zugang die nahm
sechster oktober 1935 mein lieber freund
ich bin erfreut sie zu treffen
mk ghandy
[Musik]
mit howard heimen und seiner frau sue
behandelt kann die das thema grundlegend
[Musik]
und hier denke ich ist der wendepunkt in
gandhis denken als er sagt dass die
unverfälschte botschaft der
gewaltlosigkeit in die welt gebracht
werden wird oder könnte durch die
afroamerikaner
[Musik]
20 jahre später 1955 übernimmt ein
junger pastor den staffelstab martin
luther king junior tief im rassistischen
süden ruft er eine neue sat agrana
bewegung ins leben
die doktrin der gewaltlosigkeit wie sie
von beiden martin luther king und gandhi
in indien praktiziert wurde war kein
prinzipien loser opportunismus
es ging darum seinen körper dessen
präsenz in eine friedliche waffe zu
verwandten
wir müssen die missverständnisse um die
gewaltlosigkeit beseitigen
sie hat nichts mit resignation feigheit
oder kompromissen mit der macht zu tun
im gegenteil beide gandhi und martin
luther king wussten sehr gut dass es die
herausforderung der macht war
mit nelson mandela wird der gewaltfreien
widerstand nach südafrika zurück kommen
wo kann die ihn für die in der begonnen
hatte mandela adaptiert die strategie
für seinen kampf gegen die apartheid
jede neue widerstandsbewegung festigt so
die ikone gandhi nährt den mythos von
david gegen goliath von kleinen
indischen mann der den großen britischen
herrscher besiegt am 15 august 1947 wird
indien unabhängig nach jahrzehnten der
auseinandersetzung stimmen die briten
geschwächt von zweiten weltkrieg
letztlich ihrem abzug zu die herrschaft
des britischen empire ist vorüber die
republik indien wird ausgerufen
java halal nehru der kommende
premierminister verkündet ist der welt
[Musik]
der mahatma dagegen der batu der vater
der nation trauert er zieht sich zum
fasten zurück dieses ist nicht die
unabhängigkeit die er gewollt hatte
der kampf um die souveränität war
überschattet vom kampf zwischen den zwei
größten gruppen indiens in hindus die
zwei drittel der bevölkerung
repräsentierten und den muslims gandhi
hatte alles getan um sie als inder zu
versöhnen hatte sich mit muslim führern
getroffen mit ihnen verhandelt sich
lebensbedrohlichen hungerstreiks
unterzogen um die gewalt zu stoppen
vergeblich die unabhängigkeit geht mit
einer teilung des subkontinents in das
hinduistische indien und das muslimische
pakistan einher
eine blutige teilung 14 millionen
menschen werden beiderseits der neuen
grenzen vertrieben über eine million
ermordet
[Musik]
hinduistische nationalisten die ein
ethnisch reines indien wollen weigern
sich gandhi zu vergeben dass dieser für
ein gemeinsames für alle offenes land
geforderten hatte für sie ist die ikone
zu einem hindernis geworden dass aus dem
weg geschafft werden muss
[Musik]
info tmn huub stevens wir kommen geweckt
haben
[Musik]
am 30
januar 1948 ist der mahatma tot
erschossen am hellichten tage von einem
militanten handle
seine ermordung vollendet seine legende
gandhi wird endgültig zu einem märtyrer
der unabhängigkeit und gewaltlosigkeit
und zum sinnbild für reinheit und
verbundenheit
seine asche wird in die ecken des landes
verbracht und in alle flüsse indiens
verstreut als wäre gern die endlich eins
mit seinem heimatland
[Musik]